こんにちははじめた塔です皆さん今まで生きていた中で恥ずかしい恥ずかしくてどう
しようもねぇ兄そうだ登ったことがありませんでしょうか
人には外れ c 思い出っていうのが必ずたくさんあると思うんですけどもその中でも
遠くにこれが一番ほどこのか恥ずかしいじゃないかと思われるシーンがこちら h な
ビデオを見ている時に両親と
親とかが入ってくるシチュエーションが一番恥ずかしいのではないかという設定が
成り立っておりますがその中で打った分なんですけどさせ h なビデオを見ている時
に親が入ってくるといいですねと目でと思うんですけども最近味で vr っていうの
があるんです杭 ri こういうですね
ベンリーだものでして付けてるともう償却を資格もすべてエロになってしまうんですよ
ほ最近の av をつく
合意文でこうすれども3 d スキルが目の前に広がっていて外界の情報が作画された
ままです綺麗を楽しめるというのが最近の vr av になっているんですけども
現代のスキルなビデオはもう視覚と聴覚を奪われてしまうので親が入ってきても気付か
ないんですよそういうリアリティが増した分そういうリスクも伴っているということを
ぜひあのこの動画を閉じて皆さんは学んでいってください
はい時で今回ですね av の vr に詳しい魂届ける大学の教授の方に来て
いただいておりますどうぞよろしくお願いします
アドものがよろしくお願いましては私魂とろける大学で教授やらせていただいており
ますただ
とろけるようですよろしくお願い致しますたねただ教授はたくさん vr の ap を
持つということで
そうですねあのはてぃしーわーわーあの
vr だけに限らず課金をしでそういう老舗がを可能
チームワーなるほどなるんですよ本当に何も見えなくなるんですなぁ
もう方したらここにいるのは花か女の人だけですごいです go したら部屋
ここ辺なんかされてるみたいな
一度ちょっと食べさせて頂きましたよねやらせレガートしてね5をやってもらっていた
ので初体験なぁ
うわぁじゃあ今音もってをいるしもうねちょっとああうわあああっ
持って
まあそんな穴だめよいいかわいいねーそうですねかわいい
敷かなきゃダメだよ山へ教授これやばいつはすごい3がぁああーーーーっっっ
夏子いや僕ないこうなっております一番凄い乳が痴漢4
マってどんな違うためちゃっちゃいいっ
でつけて気使いけどそういうものがパーンっ
[音楽]
ああああああ
あっはーばー
教授はこれすごいプロではバイバイ
ございません
去年はい前かがみになって参加注意ですねウイアールのベイビーですけどチェッカー
小学校探した状態で av を見ている間に両隣にお父さんお母さんが来たら
恥ずかしいで継承していきたいと思います今日のターゲットは縦面でございますはいの
ちゃんと
ご両親にアポを取ってて麺が vr を見てる間に来ていただける状態になっており
ますのでぜひご覧くださいません弱い場所
やっぱり歌てレーサーんテレビ
好きですか suke で好きですそっか宇宙破砕なもんな
双璧で ok なんでしょ av とか見たことあるもちろん
vr の av 見たことあるよはないです
ヤバイことになりましょう皆さんこれ長は初便にみたまな vr は尾根が普通の酢君
と違って落ちがすごい奴だから是非とも最後までじっくりと楽しんで頂きたいと思い
ましたねそれでちょっと目3杯早速
vr ネイビーはーいじゃあ映像の世界へ日本すごいでもうカチカチっすねああああ
いいですねいいですね味はありましたか
えっ
ん
これどうもまあしてみて良いだろう bar サイコ何
ねーめっちゃめっちゃいっすよね詳しくはせるえっと wii を買ってこう
ガッシャンじゃっ者の発射んかしちゃってるんですよ具体的に寄せどういう
シチュエーションが
えっとが公園でパンパンパウダーっているかってふぁいあーなるほどねああすごい
すごいすごい
choir すごい気持ちいいって言ってますうわあああ
ああすごい世界ですがパパじゃバイカーっぽすごいぞ大会前のでファイルと会えは言え
ダメられた日は何よなんだ理由は口をだけランサー
5000女性で俺を知りたいよあ今こうやってこうやって後ろに低スキルはこう言っ
ちゃってますってあそこがめちゃめちゃいいいっしょめちゃくれってますじゃあやばい
メジャーなにせるめちゃ速い血樹ですねっ
配位くっつけますばいばいばいまあ指だから[ __ ]は俺の行く柄ベルト数が
バスがみなさーんたてやれよ
明和会まずん
へお前はいい
明日が打った外へこんなすごい
のん by が目の前にあります
ああわあすごいはいあああああっっっブーブーいっすアース5位
でも入りました温かやシール付
明日鯉あ今日はいいとと地学ながらとろけちゃうらしいですよ阿蘇何だ
バッハ a
a 8は4枚あっこ1階地下1階
アーティこいつが5月もうアースが入ってなきゃいけないじゃねーか
それ army ケットとってみよう1回取る参加
ん
ああああああ
あ
p えっ
me
uh
うううう
me
なんでなんでてみよう今ねえっ
なくとは頭をどうぞ
me
ブーブー s 秒針の前で abe の vr 見られるときが一番恥ずかしい室でし
たぁー pou dou dou
[音楽]
ブーブーホントッ